In this problem, a UV disinfection
system is being designed for a
wastewater treatment plant.
The effective UV dose delivered to
microorganisms depends on both the lamp
output and the UV transmittance of the
wastewater.
Which of the following operating
conditions provides the highest
effective UV dose?
So, this is another quick problem to
solve if you can understand what the
problem is asking for.
There is nothing in the reference manual
to search for for this problem.
We simply need to recognize that we must
multiply both factors together for each
of the possible answers and select the
one that returns the largest value.
This is hinted at or kind of specified
in the following problem statement.
So, let's designate each of the possible
answers as a number from one to four.
Then, we can write the corresponding
lamp output factor next to the
corresponding UV transmittance factor
for the answer option.
So, for one, we've got fouled lamps,
which will be
a factor of 0.75
with excellent water with a factor of
0.95.
For option two,
we've got cleaned lamps with a factor of
0.9
corresponding to good water with a
transmission factor of 0.85.
For option three,
we have new lamps with an output factor
of one
with fair water with a transmission
factor of 0.7.
And then with option four, we have end
of life lamps with excellent water. So,
that's going to be 0.6
*
0.95.
So, if we calculate these out real
quickly, we will see that the first
option is 0.7125.
Option two is 0.76
5.
Option three is going to be 0.7.
We don't need a calculator for that.
And option four is going to be 0.57.
So, option two is clearly the largest
effective UV dose,
which is cleaned lamps with good water,
which is our second answer over here.
Some problems really can be that simple
as long as you recognize what you're
looking to solve. And that's it.